rise and shine it's aunt spresso time
good morning belief nation it's seven my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have an amazing gift
inside you that I want to see explode
out into the world
so grab your coffee and sip on today's
message find fulfillment over to you
Tony Robbins fulfillment is an art
what's going to fulfill you is
differently at first and actually you're
not gonna learn that from anybody else
and you got to find it because success
without fulfillment is the ultimate
failure and I get those phone calls all
the time for the multi billionaire
entrepreneur or politician or business
person or a person just won their
Academy Award and they're depressed and
they can't tell anybody because they got
all their goals but they're not
fulfilled because they really don't have
that sense of meaning in their life they
went for something and they got it they
achieved and if you doubt this one I'm
saying is relevant to you or us or
anyone just think about about a year and
what a month ago we lost what I consider
be a national treasure Robin Williams
how many of you loved Robin lives look
around the room keep the hands up look
and most of you didn't know him almost
anywhere you go in the world people love
Robin Williams by the way was he graded
achievement oh my god that guy he said
he want to make become a great comedian
he did that I want to make the world
laugh he did I want to make my own TV
show he did I wanna the number one TV
show he did it I want to make movies he
did I want an Academy Award for not
being funny not his skill set drama and
he did it I want a beautiful family he
did it and then he hung himself make
everybody happy but yourself not a good
plan so if I had a gift to give you it
would be maybe make a different decision
and a decision is that no matter what
happens in your life you're gonna live
in a beautiful state a beautiful state
and that could be happy that could be
grateful that could be being generous
those are all
beautiful states aren't they it could be
curious it could be fun it could be
playful you're not limited to one state
but it's different than suffering and
most people suffering and all suffering
I've ever seen I traveled 100 countries
I've dealt with presence of countries
and you know presidents of businesses
CEOs I've dealt with people in prison I
got with you name it average people
suffering always comes because you've
obsessed about something related to you
you can only be depressed if you're
focusing on yourself so now I'm
depressed cuz my kids and and they're
not doing well no you're depressed cuz
you feel you've failed your kids it's
about you it's about how you think you
what you should have done or shouldn't
have done or what someone did to you or
didn't do to you in the past or the
future which don't even exist so I have
a simple goal my goal is help people
make a decision that says I don't know
what's gonna happen you might get a
divorce even though you don't think so
you might find a family of your family
with cancer you might have your house
get burned down or have a tornado go by
and if you live in the same place it
happens every two years and you move
back we should talk but some people seem
to do that for some reason you can't
control those things I can't control
those things I don't want those to
happen to you or anybody I love or
anybody who's even a stranger to me but
they're going to happen true not
positive thinking both just the truth so
if that's gonna happen I say make a
decision now that says I'm gonna live in
a beautiful state and I'm gonna find
beauty and whatever Life brings me cuz
life is too short not to I love this
clip and I agree that fulfillment and
success look different for everybody and
figuring out what that looks like for
you what that really means to you that's
the ultimate game and that comes from
just living life that comes from
thinking about it's self-reflection
understanding what you love out of your
life and what you don't like anymore and
need to eliminate and it can also come
from exposing yourself to new ideas to
new people to new mentors to help shift
your thinking so that you can break free
of your median environment and learn
more from people who've gone on and done
amazing things it's why I've started the
top ten roses success series its iconic
on this channel and it really means a
lot to me because my goal here is to
profile all sorts of different people
from all sorts of different walks of
life and
Tony Robbins is talking about success
it's through his lens and if Donald
Trump is hakama success is through his
lens and if the dalai lama's hakama
success is through his lens and oprah
winfrey is through her lens and Priyanka
Chopra is through her lens and so my
goal here is to not say this is the only
thing that success means but to be able
to give you a wide perspective because
what the Dalai Lama says is gonna be
really different than what Donald Trump
says but you can still potentially learn
a little bit from both because the
ultimate goal is for you to figure out
what success and what fulfillment looks
like for you when I first started it was
only about entrepreneurs every video was
only about entrepreneurs and the first
top ten that we shifted from that I
think was Michael Jordan because he is a
successful entrepreneur he's a
billionaire but people associate him
with basketball in sport and when we
looked at his collection of advice we're
not gonna make a video on how to dunk
like Michael Jordan but a lot of the
wisdom that he shares is still
applicable whether you're not Jupiter or
not and when I realized that like these
perspectives matter and I don't just
want to show one side up you don't just
want to show what financial success
looks like and so the game is for you to
figure out what success looks like for
you because when Tony Robbins says it or
the Dalai Lama or Donald Trump or
Priyanka Chopra they're speaking their
truth it's what it means to them and
that may be your truth but it may not be
and so my hope is that when you watch
one of these videos you try on the Hat
you try it on and see if it fits
see if you like it see if it looks good
in the mirror you try it on and if you
don't like it you ditch it if you're
watching the top ten rules video and
only two of the points speak to you you
ditch the other eight don't worry about
the other eight those two things could
be life-changing for you keep that hat
on and disregard the rest the ultimate
game in life for you is to figure out
what happiness what fulfillment what
success looks like for you so the
question of the day today is I'm curious
how would you define fulfillment for
yourself what does that look like be is
detailed or as brief as you'd like I
would love to hear your comments leave
it down below I also want to give a
quick sharda to Jose Velez Jose thank
you so much for picking up a copy of my
book your one-word
and doing the review and posting it on
Instagram without awesome picture
I really really appreciate the support
man and I'm so glad that you enjoyed the
book so thank you guys again for
watching I believe in you I hope we
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love and
I'll see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot event spresso
I've never really been interested in
living a balanced life you know I don't
I think balanced people don't change the
world first of all I think balanced
people don't really follow a dream you
know this doesn't mean that you don't
have responsibility he's like just go to
the other part of his question how can
you have a family well sure you can have
a family and have you know but balance
is kind of like I feel like balance is
like a made-up word it's like it
invented by corporations you know to
make their employees think that they're
happy you know it's like you got this
balance like you could work at Microsoft
you know or something here in Seattle
and that there's like 10 Microsoft
people in the audience right no
disrespect to Microsoft let's get
Microsoft's Greg one out of every five
people at work so my guess that's right
you know and it's like you know you got
you got this thing and maybe you love
your job and if you love your job that's
great
but I hear from a lot of dissatisfied
people at some of these big companies
and they write in there like I'm reading
your blog for my cubicle and like you
know I had this good job and I've got my
health insurance I've got free yoga
every Thursday but I'm not really you
know fulfilled right I'm not really
fulfilled so for me I guess I'm much
more interested Network fulfilled like
you know how can you live a fulfilled
life and you can live a fulfilled life
and still pay your bills you know lots
of creative people do it lots of
unconventional people do it and it's I
would say if anything it's actually much
more common now than it used to be you
know when I first started working online
you know 15 years ago I didn't know a
lot of other people who were doing that
you know my friends thought I was
selling drugs or something we were well
I was you know but they're like online
gambling or you know whatever like
parents have no idea how the internet
works and stuff but now it's it's much
more common so I don't really like the
word balance myself so what we'd like to
do is we want to replace the word like
living a balanced life is not the goal
the goal is living off a filled life as
you try to figure out the impossible
task of juggling work and family and you
hear over and over and over again that
you just need a lot of help we just need
to be organized we need to try a little
bit harder as a very successful woman a
single mother of three who constantly
gets asked the question how do you do it
all for once I'm going to answer that
question with 100% honesty here for you
now because it's just us because it's
our fireside chat because somebody has
to tell you the truth
Shaunda how do you do it all the answer
is this I don't whenever you see me
somewhere succeeding in one area of my
life that almost certainly means I am
failing in another area of my life if I
am killing it on a scandal script for
work I am probably missing bath and
storytime at home if I am at home sewing
my kids Halloween costumes I'm probably
blowing off a rewrite I was supposed to
turn in if I'm accepting a prestigious
award
I'm missing my babies for a swim lesson
if I met my daughter's debut in her
school musical I am missing Sandra Oh's
last seen ever being filmed to Grey's
Anatomy if I am succeeding at one I am
inevitably failing at the other that is
the trade-off
that's the Faustian bargain one makes
with the devil that comes with being a
powerful working woman who is also a
powerful mother you never feel 100% okay
you never get your sea legs we're always
a little nauseous something is always
lost something is always missing and yet
I want my daughters to see me and know
me as a woman who works and what that
example set for them and I kept proud
them they come to my offices and know
that they come to Shaun to land there is
a land and it is named after their
mother in their world mothers run
companies in their world mother's own
Thursday nights in their world mothers
work and I am a better mother for it the
woman I am because I get to run
shaundalyn because I get to write all
day because I get to spend my days
making things up that woman is a better
person and a better mother because that
woman is happy that woman is fulfilled
that woman is whole I wouldn't want them
to know than me who didn't get to do
this all day long
I didn't wouldn't want them to get to
know the me who wasn't doing so lesson
number three is it anyone who tells you
they're doing it all perfectly is a liar
well I you know I think fulfillment it
fulfillment is fulfillment in YouTube
producer I kind of two different things
I think fulfillment in general as a
filmmaker for me comes from creating and
that's why you know in 2010 they put the
soundtrack on for this story so I'll try
to make it sound of style too
I left like the mainstream meet the
mainstream sort of universe I wanted to
create more so for me fulfillment comes
in creation and I always say that like
I'm a little bit of a junkie and my drug
is uploading because if I haven't posted
a movie in like a month or month enough
I get like seriously depressed and the
only thing that like makes me happy is
to get a new movie out there that
answers your question right if you had
to think of one word that's most
important to you or that sums you Apple
so it would be like a little beacon hey
believe nation if you want to know what
the most important one word is for Tony
Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey
will.i.am and Howard Schultz I have a
very special secret video for you check
the description for details